طلب رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه الفريق
عبد الفتاح البرهان السياسيين بالابتعاد
عن الجيش وتركه وشانه والاهتمام باحبابهم
بدلا من ذلك
ويتوقع البرهان في كلمه الله باقليم النيل
الازرق ان يخرج الاتفاق الايطاليه الذي
اوقع مؤخرا اييي ان يخرج البلاد من ازمه
السياسيه حسب قوله
القوات المسلحه
الديمقراطي وتدعم التحول الديمقراطي وكله
خطوات تقود الى انتقال الديمقراط للقوات
المسلحه تدعمه وهتقيف معها ونحن منانه
نشوف القوات المسلحه بعيده من السياسه
بنانا نشوف القوات المسلحه القوات
المحترفه ما عنده علاقه بالتنظيمات
السياسيه ما فيها اخوان ولا فيها يساريين
ولا فيها يمين
ومسلحه سودانيه حق السودان هي صمامه مال
هذا السودان عشان كده بنقول نحن والله
ماشي في التوافق نحن متوقع انه ما تم
توقيعه من اتفاق ايطالي يخرج هذه البلاد
من وحدته ويوحد شملنا ويحينا
معنى من دمازين مراسله الجزيره هيثم اويت
هيثم سياسي تاتي زياره البرهان الى اقليم
النيل الازرق والتي جاءت هذه التصريحات
التي اتبعناها من هناك
نعم حسن دلالات المكان والزمان والمناسبه
التي قيلت فيها هذه
الخطاب لها معاني كثيره المكان هنا في
ولايه النيل الازرق مدينه الدمازين
والمناسبه هي مهرجان الرمايه العسكري
السنوي وهو اكبر تجمع او حدث عسكري في
السودان حيث تشارك في هذه العمليه كل
الوحدات العسكريه في الجيش السوداني تشارك
في مهرجان هذا الرمايه الثانويه البرهان
حريصه ان يرسل هذه الرسائل في هذه
المناسبه همم والزمان ان هناك مشاورات
تجري الان فيما يخص استكمال الاتفاق
الايطالي وتحويله الى اتفاق سياسي وهناك
مشاورات حول ورش تدور حول عمليات كثيره من
ضمنها عمليه اصلاح المؤسسه العسكريه
والامنيه
والبرهان يبدو انه قطع الطريق امام من
يتحدثون بانه يتدخلون في عمليه اصلاح
المؤسسه العسكريه قال لهم بالحرف الواحد
لا احد يستطيع ان يتدخل في امر الجيش ان
الجيش لديه قياده هي من تقوم بعمليه
الاصلاح كان هناك اصلاح ستراه بالطريقه
التي تناسب المؤسسه العسكريه وطلب
السياسيين بالابتعاد عن المؤسسه العسكريه
والذهاب الى احزابهم وتجهيز للمرحله
القادمه للتحول الديمقراطي حرص البرهان
على التاكيد على ان المؤسسه العسكريه
زاهده في السلطه وفي العمل السياسي وانها
ستتفرق الى عملها العسكري حال
توفرت الشروط والشروط هنا يعني بها كما
قال في مناسبه العديده في حال قيام
انتخابات حره ومن خلالها تم او ستنتج عنها
حكومه مدنيه منتخبه هذه الحكومه هي التي
ستكون لها سلطه العليا وستخضع القوات
المسلحه لهذه السلطه البرهان حرص خلال هذه
المناسبه هذه الرسائل للقطار عديده
السياسيين وايضا ال- ال- الجهات التي حتى
لم تشارك في الاتفاق الايطالي لانه عندها
هذا الاتفاق بانه المخرج الاخير للازمه
السودانيه الحاليه ايضا هذه الزياره تاتي
في هذا الاقليم الذي شهد الكثير من
الاحداث القبليه المؤسفه والتي راح ضحيتها
العشرات البرهان الحرص ان يزور بعض
المناطق التي تاثرت بهذا النزاع والشاهد
ايضا توقيع اتفاق صلح بين مكونات القبائل
او اتفاق ايطالي لتمهيدا لاتفاق صبحي بين
المكونات القبليه هنا في اقليم النيل
الازرق وقال بانه ازرق اوامره للجهات
الامنيه بالتعامل بالحسم الشديد اتجاه اي
من يهدد امن وسلامه المواطنين في هذا
الاقليم حيث من مدينه الدنازين شكرا جزيلا